the Spanish and Portuguese finance
ministers may have arrived separately
but both were set on the same thing
reassuring Europe at the parliaments
invitation segundos and Mario Santana
pledged to do their best to cut their
budget deficits Ellis photo fiscal
relief alvaro suffice s in egg omelette
l defeat publico Al Capone Alonso's
volante L nueva que haces por ciento I
prácticamente Sarah Lucy de la meta en
dos mil Kinsey on the line our transport
environmental and regional projects
financed by in structural funds this
project might not see the light of day
if those funds are suspended something
Emmy peas are largely against wah wah
epidote no dono Paulo salty Makos attack
toujours Oprah booty a circus oh ho
capito not in your open before you
negate attack at once spain and portugal
have recently come through periods of
austerity and political instability the
Commission and councils say their budget
deficits are still too far away from
their targets Spain must reach a deficit
target of three-point-one percent next
year while Portugal have to fall below
it use three percent limit by the end of
this year in front of any peace who are
largely on their side the Spanish and
Portuguese ministers promise to keep up
their fiscal efforts their aim to avoid
a suspension of EU funds